انا بتشرف وسعيد ان انا اكون معاكم
النهارده
شلتوت ممثل ومذيع وبني ادم عادي وابسط مما
اي انسان يكون مدركه ما اعرفش النهارده
افتريكس العنوان الخاص
باليوم اللي احنا حاضرينه
او فكر مره تانيه ده
مصطلح مهم جدا وكل واحد ان هو يفكر فيه في
الحياه بس لو انا هاجي اتكلم عن حياتي
خلينا نبتديها من الاول واقول لكم انا
اتعلمت منها ايه وخصوصا ان حياتي ظاهريا
لاي شخص في الوقت اللي احنا فيه في وقت
الزهور احنا خلاص احنا بنمر بعصر كل انسان
معرض لظهور كبير مش لازم انك انت تكون
ممثل او مسيئه انت ممكن في مجالك في مكانك
خلاص بقيت معرض نزول كبير بسبب تطور
التكنولوجي والسوشيال ميديا
لو هرجع في بدايه حياتي انا شاب من اسره
متوسطه واقل من متوسطه ابتديت حياتي اخ من
اصل تلات اخوات بابا يا دكتور وامي صحفيه
تعبوا
من طبقه متوسطه ان هم يحطون على التراك
والدي بيقول انا عندي 14 سنه قال لي انت
لازم تشتغل ما فيش حاجه اسمها عاد في
البيت وان انت تستنى مصروفك نزلت اشتغل
عندي 14 سنه قال لي انت لازم تكون بطل
رياضي مش بهدف غير عشان صحتك وعشان والدي
كان حاطط لي مستقبل ان انا اكون دكتور
فنزلت اتمرنت جدول حياتي كل يوم الساعه
اربعه الصبح باصحاب اروح اتمرن تجديف كنت
بطل جمهوريه ثلاث سنين تجديف خلصت اليوم
من الساعه اربعه للساعه سبعه بطلع على
المدرسه من المدرسه واخلص برجع على دراستي
وعلى مذاكرتي بعد الظهر الى ان عشت حياتي
بالشكل ده فكنت بسبب الضغط والالتزامات
اللي اهلي فردوها علي ان كان في كثير
حاجات بتتعمل وده حلو على فكره
ده كان حلو جدا ان هم عملوه ده كل الشكر
والتقدير لاهله ولابويا وامي انهم حطوني
على التراك ده خلى اليومي له هدف ثم دخلت
الجامعه والدي ساعتها اقارن ان انا اشتغل
فقررت اني اشتغلت ونجحت في الشغل من منطلق
انه حط لي هدف في الوقت ده بالذات ما حدش
بيبقى عنده هدف ولو احنا سيبنا اولادنا في
الوقت ده كل واحد منا هيطلع بشكل
ما لهوش مضمون وده ممكن بنقابله دلوقتي
بنشوف شباب بيعمل حاجات كتيره من الظاهر
انها ممكن تكون مفيده لكن هي مش بتضيف له
حاجه بعد كده تمام حصل ده
اول حاجه اتعلمتها
وانا عندي 22 سنه ان ما فيش منطق وانا اسف
لاي شخص عايش حياته بالمنطق هقول لك انت
هتوصل اللي انت عايزه عشان اي بني ادم
بيتعب وبيشقى في الحياه بيوصل
بيوصل اي حد بيشقى ويتعب بيوصل ولا تقول
لي ان في واسطه ولا تقول لي ان في حد اخد
فرصتك اه في واسطه في حد بياخد فرصتك فعلا
لكن الانسان اللي بيصر على النجاح واللي
يعني بيقول انا لازم اكمل هو الشخص هو
اللي بيوصف كمان عشره عشرين سنه مدام انت
حاطط هدفك ده شايفه قدام توصل قدمت صباح
الخير يا مصر وده في مجال الاعلام ده اقوى
مجال او اكبر مدرسه اعلاميه في الشرق
الاوسط لان صباح الخير يا مصر هو اللي خرج
كبار الاعلاميين في الشرق الاوسط وفي
المجال التمثيل الحمد لله رب ربنا وفقني
وعملت اعمال دراميه حلوه نجحت بس النتيجه
ايه النتيجه
ان انا بقيت بعمل نفس الشيء كل يوم ومش
حاسس بتاثير
في الحياه ليا واما في الدراما عملت
الادوار اللي فيها سيكولوجي او العقد
النفسيه او او الانسان اللي بيشر بقى
والانسان المعقد والانسان بس النتيجه برضو
ايه انت الناس صدقت اداءك بس الناس في
الحقيقه لخط لخبطوا ما بين الشخصيتين
فاصبحت انا كشخص مش مستحب منه اول ما هو
الراجل ده الشراني احنا عارفينه ده يا لا
بقى انا مش قادر على كده كل ده انا ماشي
بالمنطق اللي هو الوقت ما كسرته الدنيا
اختلفت انا
مربياني الست
بسيطه
ظلموها اهلها الست دي الله يرحمها يا رب
هي امي التانيه اسمها توحيد رحمه الله
عليها توحيده اهلها اكلوا ميراثها ورموها
فاصبحت هي شغلها الشاغل بعد ما تعرفت على
عيلتي انها تربيني انا واخواتي
قعدت في حياتنا الى ان تمت السبعين ثم
توفت وانا في بدايه وانا في المشوار اللي
بحكي لحضراتكم ده ثم مريت بعد سنين وانا
بقدم صباح الخير يا مصر
وفي النجاح الظاهري اللي انا جريت وراه
حصل لاخويا الصغير حادثه اخويا الصغير
مكنش اخويا الصغير اخويا الصغير ده كان
ابني انا اللي كنت بربيه اهلا بيجيب له
لبسه هو كان شغل الشيخ حصل حادثه في يوم
وليله
اخويا توفى
انا فاكر اليوم ده بالظبط انا فاكر ان انا
اليوم ده انا قعدت على الارض
وبقيت قاعد شاف امي وابويا وشايف اقول لهم
ايه
انت مره واحده كل حاجه بتتهد وكل حاجه
بتتلخبط والراجل وست دول باولادك وانا مش
عارف اعمل ايه
وبقيت حاسس ان انا عايز
اتدفى وسط الناس يعني عايز حد يطبطب عليا
الواجهه اللي انا حسيته اول مره تاني مره
مش عارفه استحمله وعايز حد يطبطب عليا ومش
عايز ابين ان انا ضعيف على فكره انا مش
ضعيف لكن ده قدر
فما فهمتوش
في نفس الوقت في نفس الفتره ديت بعد ما
دفنت اخويا والوضع
بحاول اقوم منه صباح الخير يا مصر بس كان
اختياري غريب قوي يوميها على فكره قالولي
هتنزل وتعمل توك شو اخباري سياسي وتملا مش
عايز ده انا مش عايز ده انا عايز
حاجه مع الناس
عشان انا كنت حاسس
ان انا لازم اكون وسط الناس عايز انزل
الشارع ما تقعدنيش في استوديو
في الفتره ديت عملت برنامج اسمه تقدر
ونزلت في احدى القنوات الخاصه ونزلت مع
الناس وبحاولت احاول اساعد واعمل
في الفتره ديت ابويا تعب من وفاه اخويا
الصغير تعب جدا ما كانش قادر يستحمل
الموضوع ابويا كان بيهرب منها في البيت
عشان يقعد يعيط عشان مش عايز يبين ضعفه
للاسف ابويا مستحملش بعد ست شهور هو كمان
من الوجع ده
ده كتير يعني الحمد لله ده قدر اصل ده شيء
انت لا تتحكم فيه الانسان بيستريح لما
يعرف انت مش هتتحكم في شيء على فكره انت
كل ما قلنالك ان كل حاجه بتحصل حواليك هو
درس يمكن انا بحكي لكم قصص مع انا اسف
يمكن هي توجع انا شايفكم كنت بتسقفوا اللي
حواليكم كلهم وكانوا بيبسطوكو بس اللي انا
بحكيه ده هو اعمق من اي شيء لانه ده شيء
احنا كلنا عارفين هو بيحصل في الحياه لكن
لما بيجي لنا هذا الابتلاء او هذه الحقيقه
في الحياه ما بنفهمش هو ليه ربنا بيبقى
عايزنا نشهد هذا الموقف هل هو عزه هل هو
هيغير تراكك هل هو هيعلمك شيء
نزلت اشتغل لكن صدقوني بعد التلات مواقف
دول
انا هدفي في الحياه اختلف
وبعد التلات مواقف دول متهيا لي النسبه
بقت كلها تعرفني بشكل تاني خالص مش عشان
عملت حاجه مختلفه نهائيا انا هو هو انا
ممثل ومذيع بعمل نفس الشيء ما غيرتش ولا
حاجه لكن بتحسس بكل بني ادم حواليا البني
ادم المحروم من شيء هو اللي بيحس بيحتاج
اي شخص حتى لو كان هذا الاحتياج في ابسط
الامور
وبتقدر كل حاجه اللي بيبتسم في وشك تبقى
ممنون ليه انك تبتسم لي اللي بيطبطب عليك
بتبقى ممنون له انك انت بتطبطب عليا اللي
بيقف جنبك في اي شيء انت او بيحن عليك انا
ممنون ليه
لقيت نفسي في نفس الوقت ده بعد الفتره ديت
وانا بقدم برنامج العادي على التلفزيون
نزلت
بقدم فقره من الفقرات فكنت الفقره دي
تتحرق عشان ما تتحرقش لما تتعرض بعديها
بيومين قلت هطلع لايف طلعت اللايف اللايف
كسر الدنيا مع ان مليون مذيعه ومذيع
يتكلموا عن احتياج مواطنين في الشارع او
عندهم مشاكل او هم بيمروا بازمه معينه او
بظروف معينه انا ما بقيتش فاهم هو ليه انا
لما دلوقتي اجي اقول لك ليه انا ليه انا
عشان انا القدر علمني حس بالبني ادم اللي
في الشارع
بقيت حاسس ان لا بدات تجاهي بقى لما ابتدي
اسمع قدري وبقيت اطلع
تفكيري من اجتهادي وان انا لما ممثل شاطر
ابقى مذيعه نجد طب ما انا اسف طب انا عملت
ده من حققته ايه اللي خلاني اروح للسوشيال
ميديا اللي انا اقول لك بعد كل ظروف اللي
انا مريت بيها
دي ربنا وفقني ان ما فيش حد يقف في طريقي
ويقول لي انا محتاج كذا قلت طب تعالى نجرب
بقيت عايز اجرب
نجرب ما اعرفش انا هعمل اللي عندي على
العبد الساعي وعلى الله ادراك النجاح
لقيت ان حققت حاجات انا ما كنتش متخيل ان
انا ممكن احققها لو انا هاجي اعرف نفسي
دلوقتي واقول لكم تامر شلتوت لا تامر
شلتوت بني ادم بسيط كل اللي بقدر اعمله ان
ربنا عز وجل بيستخدمني ان انا احاول معاك
حاولت معاليه وفريده بنتين كان عندهم ضمور
عضلات شوكي قالوا احنا محتاجين 80 مليون
جنيه عشان نقدر نطلع ونجيب العلاج الخاص
بهم رحت لهم اول يوم انا ما اعرفش اجيب 80
مليون جنيه منين انا معرفش نعمل ده بس
هنطلع لايف طلعت لايف في اثنين في ثلاثه
في اربعه
وبعد كده جمعت السبعين مليون جنيه من
اللايفات على السوشيال ميديا
ثم اخر مره كان البنتين محتاجين ان هم
يجمعوا 10 مليون جنيه في 3 ايام عشان في
وقت ما نمتش ما نمتش مش عشان حاجه ومش
هدفي حاجه ومش هدفي نجاح او شهره عشان
اريد اتحقق عشان انا اتعلمت
يعني ايه شخص محتاج وتعلمت يعني ايه تقف
مع شخص محتاج وتعلمت ان الدنيا ديت تتلخص
انك انت ممكن تحقق نفسك
بمساعده الاخرين عشان قدر يعلمني ده واطلب
من كل حد اسعى في كل حاجه انت عايزها
واجري في كل تراجع انت عايزه واجتهد واتعب
لكن اسمع قدرك اسمع لكل الظروف اللي
حواليك واسال نفسك هو انا ليه ليه ابن
الراجل ده وليه ابن الست دي وليه انا في
الظروف ده وليه هم بيعلموني كده وليه انا
حتى دول صحابي واهم شيء بقى لو سمحتوا
قدروا الناس اللي بتحبكم قدر كل واحد مصدق
فيه قدر كل واحد بيشجعك قدر كل واحد ياخد
من وقته ومجهوده ويقول لك هتحقق هتعمل كل
التفاصيل دي اللي احنا بنديهاش اعتبار هي
اللي عملتني هي اللي خلت ان
من كوني شخص ناجح ظاهريا لشخص ناجح فعليا
علي يا فريده بقى في محمود بقى في يوسف
بقى في شباب كتير بقيت اجري وراهم عشان
نحقق حلم العلاج بقى فيه ناس كتيره بتمر
بظروف الحمد لله ربنا وفقني لده ده ده
اللي انا بكلمكم عليه على اجتهاده الشخصي
على السوشيال ميديا مش بكلمك بقى ان انا
احتجت قناه واحتجت دعم واحتجت ايه انتاج
انا انا معايا هارون وفاروق
والموبايل بتاعي ما عنديش حاجه تانيه عندي
شيرين بكر في مسؤول عن الموضوع ده بس ما
عنديش اي حاجه وعندي الناس اللي بتحبني
ابن خالتي معانا وعندي امي وعندي ابني
والله العظيم هتوصل لكل حاجه
بابسط الاشياء ان صدقت واستوعبت كل الظروف
اللي حواليك وقدرك وان انت تفهم ربك خلقك
ليه الجمله والسؤال ده ان جاوبته صدقني
هاتليله حل انا بشكركم انا اسف طولت عليكم
[تصفيق]